hey everyone I'm a be sharp and welcome
to another edition of fertility files
now today's video is a request from all
of you guys we're gonna be going over
some of the most common pregnancy diet
myths and I'm gonna be attacking them
with science yay science all right now
before we get started of course just my
general disclaimer that the information
that you're about to see is for
educational and entertainment purposes
only and you should always speak to a
health care professional about your
unique case okay let's get into this
myth number one you should not eat
peanuts while pregnant because it will
increase the risk of allergies in the
baby so this is really old school and
actually really dangerous misinformation
the good news to my fellow pregnant
mamas to be is that you're eating the
peanut butter out of the jar with a
spoon may actually be good for your babe
new research published in 2014 found
that eating more peanuts and tree nuts
during pregnancy was linked to a lower
risk of peanut and Trina allergies in
their baby
this isn't direct opposition to older
lower-quality research that found no
impact or even a higher risk of
allergies in pina loving mamas these
findings are much more aligned with the
research and recommendations on early
introduction of peanut products for
infants where we now know it's actually
much better to introduce peanuts pretty
much as soon as babe starts solids
around the six-month mark but more on
that later myth number two you need to
eat for two now it turns out the old
adage eating for two isn't necessarily
true at least it's not very accurate
unless your usual intake is grossly
under where it should be there's no need
to be consuming twice of what you're
eating right now if that were true that
would mean eating like 4,000 calories
instead of 2,000 calories which is just
not necessary to support the health and
growth of your baby I prefer to think
instead about listening to my body and
some people like to say let's try to eat
twice as healthy rather than twice as
much you guys know me I don't like
numbers but in case you're wondering
what the
recommendations are in the first
trimester you really don't necessarily
need to eat much more at all on average
by the second trimester you're looking
at an additional 350 calories or so and
by the third trimester that maybe bumped
up to maybe 500 calories or so but fYI
that is like literally a muffin not a
double portion of burgers shakes and
fries which fine of course I mean if
you're hungry it go for it but I
wouldn't make a point to try to eat a
ton extra just because you're expecting
if you're eating intuitively you
probably won't need to even think about
these numbers at all and you might just
need an extra snack or two throughout
the day your appetite is actually an
amazing guide for your needs if you just
try to cheat an in myth number three
drinking coffee
during pregnancy causes miscarriages
although a statement is pretty extreme
there is some minor truth to it now
excessive amounts of caffeine is
ultimately not great for you or for your
baby a meta-analysis of case controlled
and cohort studies suggested that
consuming too much caffeine could
increase the risk of low birth weight
infants stillbirth and miscarriage --is
so if you're typically a heavy coffee
strong tea or caffeinated soda drinker
it's best to limit your caffeine intake
to less than 200 to 300 milligrams a day
which would be no more than like two
cups of coffee or maybe four cups of tea
and that is true whether or not you're
thinking a becoming pregnant or you are
already pregnant the riskiness really
due to the fact that caffeine passes
through the placenta to the fetus
influencing its development so
personally you guys know I went decaf
and the reason for that was because a I
was on prednisone while trying to get
pregnant and caffeine is contraindicated
on that drug B for my sleep since
caffeine stays in your system for up to
12 hours and C because personally I had
so much on the line here with the IVF
and things like that that it just wasn't
worth the risk so for me les was just
safer on that note myth number 4 herbal
tea is a better option than coffee
because it's caffeine free and
all-natural
okay so for this I would say don't make
assumptions that's something that is
all-natural is necessarily better the
reality is there just isn't a whole lot
of research on whether or not
herbal teas are beneficial or harmful
during your pregnancy
Health Canada however does outline a
list of herbal teas that are considered
safe and those that should maybe be
avoided so specifically things like
chamomile teas with aloe coltsfoot
juniper berries pennyroyal buckthorn
bark comfrey Labrador tea sassafras duck
roots lobelia
and Senna Leafs are the ones to
definitely avoid while citrus peel
ginger lemon balm orange peel and rose
hip tea are generally considered safe in
moderation which would be about two to
three cups per day there is limited
research that looks at herbal medicines
and remedies but not on herbal teas
specifically so when in doubt always
consult a health professional or just
make sure to stick to a small portion
now myth number five you need to drink
two cups of milk a day while pregnant so
this really comes from the idea that
women need about a thousand milligrams
of calcium per day while pregnant and
that you can get that in about two cups
of milk per day I think we've made it
pretty clear but milk is not the only
way to get your calcium needs so you can
easily choose another fortified
non-dairy beverage or include lots of
things like legumes nuts seeds and dark
green veggies or you know you can always
just take a supplement if nothing is
sounding good right now which I get
because morning sickness myth number six
you shouldn't eat fish because of the
mercury content and it may harm your
baby okay so this myth won't necessarily
apply to my vegan followers but I will
say that the benefits of eating fish are
considered much greater than any
potential risks of eating it while
pregnant fish is rich in essential
nutrients including protein DHA EPA
omega-3s vitamin D choline and minerals
such as iodine iron zinc copper and
selenium all of which are advantageous
for women planning to become pregnant
and those who are already pregnant what
you do have to be cautious of are the
types amounts and preparation of fish so
specifically you'll want to avoid fish
that are rich in methyl mercury this
neurotoxin is able to cross the placenta
and cause irreversible damage to the
central nervous system particularly to
the babies sensitive developing brain
while in utero the major fish to avoid
include large ocean predator fish so
fresh or frozen tuna swordfish shark
king mackerel sea bass mahi-mahi grouper
amberjack escolar aka butter fish Marlin
tilefish bluefin yellowfin pickerel and
orange roughy if one of these are one of
your favorites the most you'll want to
consume during pregnancy is about 150
grams per month now can white albacore
tuna is totally okay in moderation
with about 300 grams or 10 ounces per
week or about 2 170 gram cans considered
to be safe it's also recommended for
food safety purposes that you avoid any
raw fish even if it is from a really
good sushi place you just really never
know and foodborne illness can be really
serious for you and your growing babe so
in terms of what is safe ideally you
want to aim for at least 2 servings or 5
ounces of fish per week at least one of
which should be one of the really
omega-3 rich fatty fish so examples of
safe fish include salmon trout arctic
char Atlantic mackerel herring sardines
basa tilapia Sol flounder halibut
haddock [ __ ] anchovies cod and canned
light tuna shrimp scallops clams and
mussels are also safe as well alright
next myth is you should stop exercising
to protect your baby this statement was
once associated with an increase in the
fertility miscarriage and preterm
delivery but after a lot of research
it's actually recommended for expectant
mothers to engage in at least 30 minutes
of moderate activity three times per
week regular physical activity can help
improve your mood
and promote better sleep while reducing
your risk for some diseases during the
prenatal period specifically physical
activity may help reduce the risk of
some cardiovascular diseases and
gestational diabetes plus it is
associated with improving your ability
to cope with labor and delivery and
assisting in your recovery
having said that always always always
speak to your doctor about intensity
depending on your unique case and if you
have a history of any complications like
a sub chorionic hematoma you may be
recommended to keep your activity to
things like walking or really light
weights rather than doing anything
intense you also do not want to start a
new intense program while pregnant if
you weren't doing it before pregnancy
now is not the time to be looking to get
a six-pack FYI
so just move in a way that feels good to
you
and make sure that you're hydrated and
well nourished before and after as well
next myth you can't be vegan and have a
healthy pregnancy so some people may
disagree with me but I see zero reason
why anyone would need to eat animal
products to maintain a healthy pregnancy
assuming they're otherwise eating a
relatively balanced diet and taking
their supplements in fact one study
found that high intakes of red and
processed meats potentially increase the
risk of gestational diabetes obviously
there are a lot of lean alternatives
that would not carry the same risks but
I'm just making the point that there's
no perfect pregnancy food or diet it's
really all about quality yes meat can
help provide the b12 and heme iron that
mothers-to-be have higher needs for but
a well-planned vegetarian or vegan diet
can easily meet your requirements for
protein calcium iron and essential fatty
acids just keep in mind that getting
enough vitamin b12 may require some
extra attention so if you are a
vegetarian or vegan pregnant or not
remember to incorporate b12 fortified
foods or supplements and avoid consuming
them with large amounts of vitamin C
which can reduce their absorption next
myth cooling foods like papaya and
pineapple can cause miscarriage
at the moment there's not a whole lot of
research out there that's been done that
looks at any particular food item having
a direct impact on miscarriage risk
here's the truth research and wrath and
in petri dish subjects have seen that
large amounts of a compound in pineapple
called bromelain has been linked to
uterine contractions which may
theoretically cause preterm labor but
even if this was the case in humans you
would have to eat a lot of pineapple to
make that impact ditto for papaya I've
only seen research on rats when it comes
to unripe papaya and there being an
increased risk of early labor but again
this research is on rats and in really
big amounts and not even on ripe papaya
personally I would not freak out either
way if you ate any nono foods during
pregnancy since it's really very much
more about dietary patterns than any
particular food research has found that
a diet low in vegetables and fruit may
increase the risk of miscarriage so eat
your pineapple or your papaya if you
like it and just focus on getting a
variety of fruit in your diet to switch
it up I'm gonna leave a link below with
all of the available evidence I could
find on different kinds of foods that
may or may not be safe in pregnancy so
that way you can make the most
evidence-based decisions for yourself
next myth prenatal vitamins are only for
women with vitamin deficiencies prenatal
vitamins are not just for women with
vitamin deficiencies or even just for
pregnant women
in fact Health Canada recommends that
women of childbearing age take these
multivitamins to ensure a healthy
pregnancy because hey sometimes mistakes
happen and you want to be prepared there
is a lot of research available that's
linked to adequate folic acid
supplementation and a decrease in the
risk of neural tube defects so it is
recommended that women of childbearing
age take folic acid supplements in
addition to having a diet rich in folate
and that is true before conception and
of course during pregnancy a lot of moms
also opt to continue the prenatal
vitamin after pregnancy
to just help with rebuilding their
nutrients stores as
especially if you're breastfeeding and
your nutrient stores are still very high
however it's worth noting that not all
multivitamins are the same I definitely
recommend choosing methylated folate
instead of folic acid most supplements
will have folic acid because it's more
stable but your body then has to convert
it to active methylfolate and up to 60%
of women have a gene variant that
hinders this conversion this gene is
also linked to PCOS and miscarriage so
just to be safe I would always choose a
supplement with methylated folate if you
have that option next myth eating too
much sugar will cause gestational
diabetes now when we think about
diabetes sugar is usually the first
thing that pops into our mind however
with the emergence of research over the
years we now know that the cause of
diabetes is really not that simple the
risk factors for gestational diabetes
include things like high maternal age
weight family history having multiple
births and a previous birth of a large
baby during pregnancy
even healthy women tend to be more
insulin resistant in general to promote
additional glucose getting to the fetus
especially women who are over the age of
35
unfortunately this puts pregnant women
at a higher risk for gestational
diabetes not the act of eating sugar but
what about the indirect role of sugar in
weight gain and gestational diabetes
well we know that eating too much of
anything can cause weight gain and
research has linked excessive weight
gained higher risk of gestational
diabetes that fact however is not
telling the whole story it's often the
case that excessive weight gain during
pregnancy may be the result of
restrictive dieting prior to pregnancy
so asking a mama to be to go on a
restrictive diet is potentially putting
them at risk of continuing on this
dangerous diet rollercoaster the best
thing that we can do is not diet or
restrict well sugar per se is not
necessarily the culprit having a healthy
diet in general definitely may help once
that he found that a Mediterranean or -
style diet helped reduce the risk of
gestational diabetes suggesting that a
diet rich in thigh
fruits vegetables and whole grains and
lower in red and processed meat may help
lower the risk so try to focus on what
you're including in your diet rather
than what you're cutting out well
friends I hope that this was helpful and
enlightening not just for my pregnant
mamas but really for all of you who know
someone who's pregnant or may one day
want to be pregnant or support a partner
through a healthy pregnancy if you have
any other pregnancy IVF or infertility
questions that you want me to cover in
my fertility files definitely leave me a
comment below and as always do not
forget to Like comment share subscribe
and I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye